[Música]
está con nosotros jorge hurtado aquí en
el estudio de directo américa para
comenzar a hablar de economía los hechos
principales del día como por ejemplo el
banco central europeo- jorge subió los
tipos de interés por primera vez en 11
años esto qué significa para la economía
mundial y europea que el banco central
europeo se suma ahora al resto de bancos
centrales del mundo que están intentando
subir los tipos de interés para tratar
de frenar la inflación que es un
fenómeno global la subida fue de 50
puntos básicos o 0,5 puntos porcentuales
un movimiento que el organismo sólo
había dado otras dos veces en su
historia la razón santiago el impacto de
la inflación en el poder adquisitivo las
continuas restricciones de suministro y
una mayor incertidumbre por la guerra en
ucrania que tiene un efecto moderado en
esa economía la subida de 50 puntos
básicos tendrá un efecto inmediato en el
aumento de las hipotecas y de los
préstamos así como a sí mismo que hará
más difícil el acceso de los países más
endeudados a los mercados también otro
anuncio importante fue que europa dio a
conocer la creación de un instrumento
anti fragmentación bautizado como
mecanismo de protección de transmisiones
que busca evitar una crisis de deuda en
los países periféricos y también se
calmaron un poco los mercados en la
jornada de hoy porque rusia reanudó la
actividad de envío de gas hacia europa a
través del norte extremo uno bueno y lo
hizo con una capacidad del 40 por ciento
justo la que tenía antes de estos 10
días de bloqueo por mantenimiento la
noticia que al modo el mercado que
reaccionó con una caída del precio
norström controlado con un 51 por ciento
del capital por la gasística rusa
gazprom
estuvo ausente por estos 10 días de
mantenimiento la capacidad normal del
gasoducto es de 167 millones de metros
cúbicos diarios pero ahora ronda los 67
millones de metros cúbicos diarios es
decir un 40 por ciento de esta capacidad
rusia despejó la incertidumbre con una
reanudación del norte ya que europa no
estaba segura de que iba a reabrir el
grifo la unióneuropea llenó sus
depósitos de gas el 64 por ciento de su
capacidad el objetivo es el 80 por
ciento para noviembre previo a la
temporada de invierno pasemos ahora a
temas de américa latina- porque avanza
en la ciudad de asunción en paraguay la
reunión de los países del mercosur que
han discutido estos cuatro países el
tema económico fue clave sobre todo
ahora con los precios de los
fertilizantes a nivel internacional
elevado bolivia resaltó los proyectos
que emprende para proveer fertilizantes
como la urea y el abono en afecta a la
región el representante de bolivia
destacó la vocación productora de
alimentos que tiene el mercosur y
aseguró que su país apostó y seguirá
apostando a la integración
bolivia tiene una planta de urea y
amoniaco que se prevé que alcance el 85
por ciento de su capacidad para
diciembre de este año con una producción
de unas 600 mil toneladas de
fertilizantes y un excedente exportable
del 90 por ciento a propósito bolivia
está en un proceso de adhesión plena al
mercosur desde hace casi una década
pasemos ahora a temas de eeuu porque
retiró a nicaragua de la lista de países
que pueden enviar azúcar a eeuu con
bajos impuestos de importación bueno
esta restricción hace parte de las
medidas de washington para presionar el
gobierno de daniel ortega que es acusado
de autoritario eeuu reparte anualmente
cuotas de importación de azúcar por país
impone gravámenes bajos a los envíos que
no alcancen el límite en nicaragua que
obtuvo una cuota de más de 22 mil
toneladas métricas del año
presupuestario del 2022 fue excluida de
la lista para el 2023 nicaragua exportó
el año pasado azúcar a eeuu por valor de
83,5 millones de dólares según los datos
del departamento de agricultura de ese
país la decisión de washington afectaría
a cuatro ingenios azucareros a unos 800
productores y sus familias así como a
inversionistas de guatemala colombia
españa eeuu y de nicaragua el sector
azucarero nicaragüense produce cerca de
2 millones de toneladas anuales de las
cuales más de la mitad se exporta los
ingresos por 200 millones de dólares que
genera este sector representan alrededor
del 4 por ciento del producto interno
bruto nacional
nicaragua y con esto nicaragua da empleo
a unos 150 mil personas e impacto
entonces en la economía nicaragüense
veíamos unas lindas imágenes de su
ciudad la ciudad de managua vamos a
oakland eeuu porque hay un grupo de
conductores de camiones iniciaron una
huelga porque están protestando bueno
los camioneros protestan contra una ley
estatal dificulta el transporte de
mercancías por parte de contratistas
independientes y que podría limitar
también la mano de obra en un contexto
en el cual pues es bastante complejo
tratar de conseguir empleados la
protesta que comenzó el lunes está
bloqueando el movimiento de carga dentro
y fuera de las terminales del puerto que
es uno de los 10 puertos de contenedores
más activos de ese país la situación
está grabando ya los problemas de la
cadena de suministro que han provocado
atascos en los principales puertos y
acumulación de mercancías en los muelles
estas protestas se producen cuando los
fabricantes de juguetes y otras
industrias entran en su temporada alta
de importaciones muchas gracias jorge es
todo por el momento de la economía a
continuación en directo américa el
debate
[Música]